Toy Story for people very excited by it
2035 we do have fear thousand 36 this is
the most amazing experience of my life
is that hope it's like become number one
Hanks and I become friends over this
thing I really like this character what
gets me is that sometimes I'll see like
a commercial with a gut somebody else's
voice doing it yeah like for commercials
or yes if I go to Disney on Ice I got a
six year old don't take her and I go
what who's that
yeah no gosh darn it I want my voice of
that thing so I'll put some poor kid out
of work cuz I need their so 60 bucks
but they're so scrubbed on this thing
they won't tell me anything about it
except least I start doing buzz in about
three weeks so it's a series of my two
years after it gets done but if these I
got a preliminary idea and I can't tell
you anything about it because I want I
really respect their but it's really
good but these guys are their flaw I
have to say that front that franchise
those are flawless I think those are
great in American films I really think
eyes or movies are great and they're all
right right and they're really yeah how
do you how do you bat a thousand is
don't gonna get this there Satan
worshippers there's something weird over
there
one guy loud they jus isn't laughing one
left the guy in the bed oh yeah
oh yeah hey thanks for watching be sure
to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography